hey everybody welcome to the quarter
past founders Edition where Nikko and
myself are gonna shoot the breeze for a
little bit here we have a couple things
to talk about and get off our chests we
have to talk about kind of our
experiences of as filmmakers in a
youtube world we have to talk about our
experiences on the set of life line the
hotly debated dramatic experience and
we're also going to talk about the
future of robots taking our jobs let's
see how it goes
don't forget to subscribe if you liked
it at any time any you hear something
you like smack that subscribe button
welcome sorry - welcome to week two one
welcome to the founders cast this is the
special edition of the quarter cast
where Nikko myself figure it all out
how's it going Yuko it's good have you
realized that what sang something in
unison is like the cringy esteem Mike
what sing that like saying what great
welcoming people the corridor Casa the
founder speaking one welcome to the
corridor cast starring during like yeah
it's pretty bad I don't this cuz this
feels fake cuz there's always someone in
their group who's like just reminds me
of children's TV shows yeah I guess
that's why yeah so do you want to talk
about what's an interesting thing we can
talk about well what's going on I mean I
know I see you every day but but
seriously what like so how's it going
hots go and I'm working on this
battlefield commercial yeah yeah that's
how was that going how that's been a
little tricky yeah well uh for those of
you guys who are not in the corporate
world like me and Sam also we are
thankfully not in the corporate world
there's a lot of people that need to
improve things and those change the
command you have a wild variety of the
types of people that are having them and
the things they like yeah as especially
when the chain of command involves
Swedish people as well oh yeah so yeah
time barriers language barriers
everything although I all difference in
every Swedish person I've ever met has
fantastic grasp on English yes
surprisingly good everyone from scanning
I don't know it's crazy let's just say
that the very first edit of this
battlefield commercial went in one
direction and once the folks are add I
saw it it went in a very different
direction yeah and it's been going all
over the place I've it's been like turn
to use a compass in the Bermuda Triangle
yeah I I can imagine well it's I guess
he here's your's here's the thought I
mean you look at indie developers you
look at a big developer like dice and
obviously with more people comes more
oversight and larger chains of command
but then also you start to be capable of
creating things that are far greater
than anyone else is capable of mhm and
so it's kind of like this every single
time I talk to people about their
commercial experiences it's always the
same thing so that's that like there's
that chain of command it's something
like that but at the same time their
aspirations and I'm even speaking for
myself here it's like well I want to
have all the money and spend it on the
big productions and dude the crazy stuff
but it's it's like how do you kind of
grapple with both is is it necessary to
have these huge groups of people and
change the commands to accomplish great
tasks or I don't think so at all no I
mean if you need like an army pumping
out art yeah but like the best the best
videogames the ones that are even the
most successful are not successful
because they have huge teams working on
them they're successful because the
ideas I mean yeah the popular videos on
YouTube are popular not because of the
production quality they're popular
because of the ideas yeah it's just the
idea it's you only need one person to
come up with a good idea obviously
there's execution on it too but this is
something a Brennan has pointed out
which is currently the video game
industry is headed around like huge
teams of hundreds if not thousands of
people just pumping out art for the same
game over and over and over the
Assassin's Creed series is just the same
bass game with new art every year mm-hmm
yeah
so I don't know I the games that catch
my eye are the ones that have ideas you
know minecraft was just a new idea yeah
escape from talk I've been playing for
years a new idea I just got into Dark
Souls that's a different idea than any
other game yeah um yeah of course now
they're getting into the whole art thing
where they just let's play the same game
again to some new
yeah yeah yes I guess you'd say that but
it's still working the thing is this the
gameplay in Dark Souls is is so robust
that it can kind of it can last yeah but
again but once again still Dark Souls
fairly large team of people to create
that you know imagine you're shooting a
commercial for from software is it just
from just from yeah from software so the
games come from software or something
Dean's come from from software oh so you
know you imagine working with those guys
I mean well first off a Japanese
developer I've heard many things
there's rituals in you have to court
them rituals yeah what kind of rituals
well there's it it's there's a business
in Japan has a completely different like
method from everything I've ever heard
I've heard that if you're doing business
with someone in Korea you have to get
drunk with him first yeah I like that
idea about not a bad idea so you gotta
know somebody yeah you really have to
you have to make sure no one's gonna
like say anything really stupid
yeah I'm engaging relaxed mode with
microphone now for those of you guys who
are listening to audio only version of
the podcast I'm now just holding the
microphone and leaning back in my chair
so everything he says is more relaxed
now imagine him killed
yeah just had to relax a little bit here
and really let down my guard so I back
well yeah I find that interesting though
there's the different methods I guess of
I guess deal-making yeah hey what's your
favorite video game
my favorite video game well we talk
about video games what's your favorite
video game all-time you know it's it's
it's Jay changes I mean of all time I
think I actually had the most fun
playing Halo one yeah I was a good game
actually had the most most endorphins
were released during Halo one yeah
because of a single player being
groundbreaking and because of in-house
like Ethernet cable LAN parties with
four TVs and 16 like happy I've never
done that since then I've never yeah
partied at someone's house and brought
ethernet cables at the same time yeah
you know and that's like it's so fun
it's so fun to do that so
yeah yellow one I'm ever had that little
TV where when somebody got the health
pack and the screen would turn white the
TV couldn't put out enough power so the
other half of the screen would go dark
split screen wouldn't be able to see for
a moment while the other person finished
healing yeah
my favorite video game of all time
that's a good question I always say for
the dead space why I think I always used
to say full throttle and just because I
really like to point and click adventure
games that one built a really cool world
mmm I feel like it's really dated now at
this point to say that I don't know
games that gave me good vibes SimCity
2000 Goldeneye was good perfect I was
even better halo 1 was great I mean
these days the game I really enjoyed
over the past couple years here escape
from tarkov really stood out to me it's
like the dark souls of shooters you said
SimCity 2000 I always felt that was a
very interesting game because it was
installed on most computers in
elementary schools it was like for me
the last three years of my like four
five and sixth grade very young SimCity
2000 was installed for some reason on
almost every computer I came across
mm-hmm and I wonder I'm just curious
like I guess there's a there must have
been an educational value in it right
there must have been a big debt of city
planners and they just needed to get
more of them into the system all those
kids at a young age do you think they
have fortnight installed on all
computers and like school libraries no I
bet you well the teachers would think no
the students would say yes hmm
yeah every like everyone like secretly
installs it that's installed everywhere
yeah that makes sense yeah do you think
that for tonight for graphing
calculators yet it's probably like yeah
like a text version or something like
that like a story story based version
like a linear choose-your-own-adventure
fortnight thing you're getting shot at
do you wish to a shoot back or B go
before
that's like the answer every question so
other than working on the commercial Oh
like what else like I just shot a video
with Clinton yesterday how's that going
it's going good
I I miss shooting videos I wish I could
shoot them more shooting videos is kind
of fun is is really fun what's like
you're a photographer at a fashion shoot
you know what shooting videos uh-huh
that's like that's why it's fun because
you're sitting there going like just
look cool oh yeah this camera I'm trying
to make you look cool like let's do it
okay cool I wasn't sure where you're
going with that
yeah it is fun yeah it's well it's nice
but you get to just like focus on make
stuff making stuff look cool and I got
some new lights I got to play with those
I mean like there's the kind of shoot
where's just one actor in a dark spot so
it's like it's all about just making it
look cool cool lights how do you make it
look cool here's the secret to making
stuff look cool guys you have one light
on the edge and then by the edge I mean
like slightly behind the person not all
the way behind the person is kind of
behind the person and you tinted a
certain color whatever color you want
doesn't really matter just make it a
color and then you have the next light
be at a some point it's not directly
from the camera direction so like above
them or to the side and then last but
not least if you can't afford any set of
the background like we have behind Sam
here oh wait a second doing that on
accident well it's funny yeah well audio
only version everyone is gonna suffer
here but these lights worked out pretty
well pretty happy with it check it out
one hits the face the other one
accidentally edge lights you from that
camera yeah perfect it's got an edge
light right here and I feel right here
and then that corner was boring so he
put a pink light there okay why'd you
pick pink this time tuitions my um yes
my favorite color we talked about this
ahead of time
yeah well you shot a commercial yeah
it's super cool you're working with the
Swedes to get it done
all right shot a video yesterday with
Clinton yeah um and he made it look nice
with lights I did okay so I'm gonna shot
on red which is nice too yeah yeah it's
hard not to just shoot everything on red
look at all these new camera platforms
you see like the a7 or anything else and
you're like oh it would be sweet to have
a smaller rig but but you pay yeah I've
been thinking about the perfect camera
recently I don't think about the perfect
camera all the time actually the perfect
camera to me is a camera that lets you
do any move you want and it doesn't get
in your way like so here's the thing
about cameras they look the best when
they have a large sensor that lets see
you get a lot of dynamic range
resolution doesn't matter too much just
a large sensor because a larger sensor
means and get nice childhood at the
field yeah and then you want that
dynamic range and you want low light
capabilities okay
okay so that's the sensor that's that's
what needs to happen kind of internally
on the camera already having a large
sensor rules out like 90% of cameras and
then having good dynamic range rules out
like the remaining 5% so it leaves like
5% of cameras mm-hmm so okay I can still
handle that 5% of cameras there's a lot
of cameras out there there's I guess
there's still a couple that fulfill that
but then the thing is outside of that
all these cheap cameras are come up with
these great things that like make using
a camera easier like for example the
camera is at Carmichael Nick shoot with
to focus they just touch the screen on
what they want the camera to focus on
and Canon has built dual pixels that can
tell when the light is focused
it doesn't need to search for it doesn't
get analyze the frame you just tell
wouldn't like the light beams coming in
when the photons are coming in in
parallel and automatically instantly
focuses that's great that's missing from
any high-end cinema camera you can't
just touch the screen until it where to
focus you have to hire a whole person to
pull focus so you have to get really
good at doing it yourself which is hard
to do in the camera weighs 30 pounds
well I think it's also limited purpose
though at the same time because let's
say you are shooting someone you have
them in frame of that you have them
framed up there on screen I guess you
can you could tap on that if it's the
touch screen they'll be in focus but now
they move are we talking you want to
shoot you want to shoot with autofocus
that Canon yeah I want to shoot with
autofocus
like autofocus it's not that hard of a
problem anymore they've solved it yeah
but what if it messes up well you can
always go to manual but when was the
last time you saw autofocus mess up on
the corridor crew channel hated I'll put
it this way how many times have you
biffed the focus yourself
I've lost count autofocus definitely
just screws up less times than I screw
up at least some the new cameras so you
mentioned a camera that can focus
automatically those features that'd be
great
it would be but then here's the big
thing smooth movements like smooth
cinematic movements it's been like the
dream for decades like you have tripods
and dollies and jibs and glide cans and
like like Devin Supertramp made a whole
career off of smooth camera movements
definitely I mean
he's more than just a smooth camera
movement kind of guy but he has that
going from so the gimbals will come out
it's not like there's the Devin Graham
signature tripod I would buy that
what's the tripod you use in all your
videos the most for the most stable of
frames Wow nothing's moving at all is
this a photograph no silly you're on
YouTube my trap is really good tripod
you can tell the bad tripods when the
footage still Wiggles once the cameras
on the tripod like the ones we're using
right here can't tell if it's working no
the good tripods signature of us these
are a signature Sam Dworsky and Nico
Signature Edition tripods yeah they've
come with three legs they'll ball on
Amazon all right anyways to finish my
little spiel here so Gimbels have come
out and gimbals are great that let you
basically do all those kinds of camera
moves yeah it cost hundreds of thousands
of dollars in the past but now you just
use a little fancy gimbal and it keeps
the camera steady but you need to like
camera to do that yeah and the biggest
issue so you can't pull focus at the
same time you can't be holding on to the
lens of the camera when the camera can't
let you touch it because it's on a
gimbal so here I am using the red the
image quality is great but I'm just
thinking about all these cool things I
could be doing if it was on a gimbal and
all I need to do is be able to pull
focus with those lenses like
electronically and I've tried but it
doesn't work cuz nobody's actually spent
the time to make it really work because
software through your phone and software
over wireless
usually sucks and if somebody just did
that if someone you could just take a
red
make it so you could pull focus
wirelessly using electronic focus
control and blends motors and I could
map that right on a gimbal I would be so
happy and they would probably put a
hundred people out at nine hundred they
put thousands of people out of jobs in
Hollywood but it'll never happen because
of that reason I remember when they
added auto focus like crappy autofocus
but they added out-of-focus and on the
forums there was an uproar about people
saying how they're gonna make a C's lose
their jobs are you for real yeah I'm
real no screw all those people ya know
what the more jobs I can kill the better
there we go I said it yeah you know
actually I agree with you but it sounds
awful but I agree with you hi welcome to
technology Elon Musk you're killing too
many jobs it's the same concept well I
mean on a bigger scale all these
automotive factories are gonna shut down
it's like no they're just gonna work for
Tesla well here's here's my point of
view on it like for example they're
putting up computer kiosks at McDonald's
so you no longer order from a cashier
you just go up and hit the screen and
the burger pops awesome that's mercy
exactly like yeah you're killing a job
but let's be real with ourselves isn't
that kind of a waste of human potential
yeah it's to just be there and be the
equivalent of a touchscreen where
something just gives you an input and
you give them an output like people are
so much more than that
and yeah I know people have to like
relearn things and learn new scales and
there's a painful process to this and
callously just missing it right now in
the podcast but no there's nothing
callous about this this is really
fascinating stuff stuff that people have
to start grappling with as more and more
jobs get replaced well we've seen that a
little bit in America here as
manufacturing has disappeared what's a
rose instead is design design has become
the big thing for people to get jobs in
you know design and art and creation you
are you are using your actual skills as
a human being to problem-solve and to
create and to be creative rather than
being the man who pulls the lever to
make sure that the machine your thing
punches the diode in the right spot I
think that's fascinating because if you
think about that from a design
perspective everyone complains about how
they have to throw away their iPhone
every year to buy another one yeah and
it's like obviously that's a
generalization but every two years what
I'm getting out of the generalization
what I'm getting at is that if you think
about that like think about a product
other than
a pair of good shoes that you've used
for more than a year you know like what
and like what are they other than like
clothing which is like you know dumb
simple mm-hmm you know it's it doesn't
break you know it doesn't crash you know
your shoes don't get firmware updates
but like the fact that we have products
coming out at such an unparalleled rate
because of the fact that they have Ekta
become obsolete so quickly I think I
think you're right in the sense that we
wean we have this demand for more
designers and more
I guess creators of products because
every Christmas even even this here you
see portal from Facebook don't buy it
obviously you don't want to put a
security cam from Facebook in your house
that's for sure for a second I thought
you're saying this new portal game no no
if there's a port a product called
portal they started advertising it oh
yeah and then and then I think something
happened and then I saw from Facebook
slapped on to it afterward but you look
at that that's a new product like every
single year we're seeing anything from
like do new types of like Apple TVs to
chromecast's the Smart TVs the things
like in the this accelerated rate of
Technology means that we need new
designs every month yeah for these same
products that we already are using and
having and it's that if there's this
there's this need and demand and this
this like something something's out
there that's that's kind of feeding this
yeah so it's it's really fascinating
yeah and you know it's not to say like
at a factory still needs skilled
craftsmen like mm-hmm
that's very on a very important job too
but still creativity that's still I
still applying your depth of human
knowledge and skill it's just like when
you are literally just part of an
algorithm just part of a function and
it's just like well we couldn't make a
robot that was dexterous enough but I
had enough dexterities dexterous ordered
yeah that's right we couldn't make it a
robot that had enough next area to pick
up this box and twisted in the right
direction so we need the human being to
do that like yeah that's where it's just
yeah I would love to see those jobs
eliminated I would love to see people be
more than that well unfortunately an AC
is fitting that description well when
they're just pulling because we need
something dexterous and
turn something yeah 45 degrees 90
degrees and the funny thing is
technically that comes in the crosshairs
of stuff your description yeah and the
funny thing is like anybody who's like I
don't know if you've actually worked
with an AC there's so much more than
just somebody pulling focus like yeah
actually I totally agree everyone who's
assisted me on camera has made the shots
better yeah in the sense that like they
they become as instrumental to the shot
as the composition itself mm-hmm because
they're directing focus they're
directing attention therefore a
directing story
therefore they are what's also a or they
are my creative collaborator you know
it's also like help me actually take
care of the camera help me troubleshoot
it very I move it over here we've got a
set up over here like and that's the
only silly thing about that everybody
getting angry about out-of-focus killing
jobs it's not gonna like in any like if
all your AC is doing is pulling focus
you are not running a very efficient set
I don't know yeah totally I mean maybe
they actually movies are so screwed up
movies are super screwed up
you wonder why no yes I need to know
here's my movies are screwed up it's
frankly it's because the movies make
millions of dollars and they spend
millions of dollars like when you start
throwing on two hundred million dollars
for a movie you are screwing up the
economy so bad for everybody else that
doesn't have 200 million dollars to make
a movie and you are so like warping the
sense of value for the things you do on
a film mmm like yeah you guys might
already know this but Sam and I we
filmed a YouTube read series called
lifeline yep and it was a union shoot
yeah it was well it's weird is weird
shoot there's a weird well we didn't
really bring anything to it we weren't
able to really bring when you look at
your final look it like honestly I might
I don't know how you do this but
internally I have I have milestones for
myself it is as as like someone working
in the career of filmmaking like I have
bloody milestones basically it's a meter
it's a zero to 100% meter basically of
when I set out to make something and I
come out the other side how close was
that to what I set out to make like it's
like going into a blueprint for a house
that's like a square and you come out
the other side with a triangle and you
go oh the hell did that happen you know
and I wanted to make a square like what
went wrong and I've noticed like on
YouTube anyways
I set out to make a square and I get a
square I'm starting and I'm starting to
sew and so for me like that's the my
zero to 100 M like I'm starting to hit
these like 85 90 s of like division like
that moth video mm-hmm that is that is
exactly what I was imagining four sides
same size every degree seriously every
single shot every single line was so on
point so close and so I took that as a
very large personal success mm-hmm but
then I looked at lifeline and if I watch
it and I'm like I'm like someone else
could have made that like I don't
recognize parts of it you know so so I
don't know what to get that a number
it's like a 60 what happened like how
did that happen well I mean you were
there but I'll recount this let's take a
deeper look at it take a deeper we can
take a deeper dive because the the
common story is is the the everyman
tries to make a creative vision and the
man stomps on him and oppresses him and
blah blah and so you know any number of
variants of that story is the common
explanation for why something like that
like a vision or working on something
creatively could go wrong you have other
people they have other opinions
sometimes those opinions are louder and
stronger for various reasons mm-hmm and
therefore things go off course and you
just hold on as tight as you can but the
deeper version is that I mean in a sense
you could you could argue we're out of
our element a little bit mm-hmm
and it's less about other people's
visions but ours and our expectations
going into it and well how he's out of
your element well the way you opened it
the union thing the Union shoot thing so
yeah I open with that union thing yeah
and this isn't an anti-union trade but
you know ultimately you know we're jack
of all trades here on YouTube and that
that that environment of a union shoot
is is not conducive mm-hmm to creating
the products that we create here on our
own channels in the sense that we don't
we are not allowed to hold cameras you
know we have that call with the union
rep saying hey this is going on our
YouTube channel where we make youtube
videos of people like you know blowing
stuff up and we're known for shooting
all our own videos so can we get a
waiver on this Union shoot and they're
like no looks like let's just say that
again and see if we get the same answer
that was like so confusing you know and
so that was the kickoff basically that
was that literally was the kickoff to us
going oh man all right so we're just
gonna sit in these director's chairs and
like effectively like slowly try to tell
everybody what we want yeah like first
of just doing it ourselves
like almost half-assedly because like
there are so many moving parts on the
set and there are so many frankly
attitudes it was a bunch of like I mean
I mean there was great people on that
set who were incredibly talented but for
them to work on a YouTube original
series many of them including actors and
crew definitely had this there was this
aura that it this this project was below
them
yeah and that was from day one basically
you know it's like they're like oh this
is below beneath us I worked on this TV
show or I worked on this movie and now
I'm working on a YouTube original and so
just lifted by a bunch of YouTube these
kids these children these youtubers you
know and so two year old children yes
yes well we were some of the youngest
people on the set that's true you know
and so it's really hard to combat that
you know and if so eventually you kind
of start getting to this point where
it's like
first off I can't actually do anything
on this set like if I wanted to actually
make it a true difference other than
like going around and consoling each
consoling each person like I guess
that's that's what directors have to do
on huge sets mm-hmm they're just like
you know they're teddy bears basically
where they're like oh don't worry
friends you know it's like or I don't
know I don't know see that it's like the
profess the Pathet this is the issue
it's like what what is the method of
action to correct that course when
you're on it well we talked about that
actually by the way my favorite didn't
bit we did actually my favorite Union
bit no playback your modern era it's you
were using red can't it's it's it's yeah
it's like it's going into an antique
store you can't hit playback without a
you can't hit the play button to watch a
clip you just filmed it's it is because
that's a union position to do playback I
know see this is what we're talking
about killing jobs yeah I know I know
it's it's sad it's sad that we have to
talk about it like this but ultimately
that's that is like the true end result
here but whatever so I'm sorry I didn't
mean it tangent that no no it's all good
it's all good but we had talked about
after lifeline was finished like what
wouldn't wrong so to speak and for all
it's worth we're talking about life on
it like it's some disaster it wasn't a
disaster it's just your average TV show
which is exactly what Sam and I try not
to do yeah yeah that's the big thing
it's like it was it's the most by the
books by the numbers TV show when you
watch it and that's the thing yeah we
realize that we're just cogs in a
machine and it's a machine that no one
wanted us to try to invent something new
in yeah well and this is kind of also
another issue too it's well this is a
tangent here a little bit but either way
so what's tough for me though with that
project and lifeline is in this world of
social media in YouTube um you know it's
not like a director in the 90s who like
makes a movie and then it goes out there
and you're not like oh that sucked
and the director is like oh it's like no
the director is they're either like in
the e YouTube right now these us as
directors where there is like almost the
face on the poster - for most of these
projects now so it's like
us posting lifeline on our channel feels
feet like feels the same way as me going
onto my personal Instagram or my
personal Facebook page that my friends
and family are on and I'm from and
posting something there as like here's
something that represents me in my
opinion you know it's like no like for
that lifeline felt like dragging my work
in through the front door and like going
like don't you know I don't want to talk
about it you know but everything we make
is is at that level though where it's
like anything that goes on the corridor
crew or quarter channels and even this
podcast channel you know it's like that
is it's not just like oh here's Sam at
work this is it feels like here's
something that has to represent me 100%
when it's released mm-hmm
you know and so that's why I sit here
thinking about these projects over and
over anyway so I'm not sure if that
feels the same way for you sometimes you
know to have that separation or if
they're combined I don't know but it's
something it's been an inescapable for
me for the last few years yeah I mean I
always think about that I think about
old projects and what we could have done
differently and you know what right well
it didn't and part of lifeline I feel
like I should just been an [ __ ] I
should have lived just been more of an
[ __ ] I should've been an entitled
diva director which is what they were
all expecting it's what they were all
excited everybody was kind of expecting
us to be [ __ ] and we weren't we were
nice and we were excited wanted to be
very hands-on with everything we're very
excited yeah I'm super inexperienced
because of that and if we're not sound
were inexperienced it's just we've we've
lived a happy life of being filmmakers
rather than the jaded life of being part
of the Machine I mean I don't know
actually brings us back to we're
creating that better life and as I said
earlier with video games it's not about
how big your team is it's about your
ideas yeah
and you just have to come up with good
ideas and you just do those who don't
spend a lot of money yeah so filmmaking
budgets they've warped that world of
filmmaking where somebody expects that
when they show up on set they're gonna
get paid multiple thousands of dollars a
day Bruce Willis granted he's a big
actor he costs a million dollars a day
yeah no one seems to get upset about
actors getting paid a lot of money I
already gets upset
CEOs getting paid a lot of money well
that is is it supply and demand yeah a
little bit
but it's also the fact that like the one
movies make that much money so he's
expecting like well I'm the lead deck
actor or hell I'm going keeping your
shots in focus you guys are making that
much money give me a cut that makes
sense but it's the fact that that
economy is so screwed up around that
that the art of just making films as
like four million dollar a three million
dollar a couple hundred thousand dollar
productions like that's like becomes so
ignored and this becomes so atrophied in
the industry but that's where like
that's where like the the interesting
ideas happen you know it's obviously the
interesting ideas happen on that smaller
scale yeah they really start very few
people know how to make films in that
scale and then no one's built equipment
or people to make films at that scale
everybody's trying to like shoehorn like
DSLRs and the film cameras because
that's like that's the equipment that's
anywhere near being built for low-budget
filmmaking yeah I guess so
I mean but but it's like the only people
who have ever been able to profit off of
low-budget filmmaking is YouTube yeah
like you do is like the only thing and
it's like until like I mean I don't know
what the physical version of that is
that's the problem because that's what
you would have to say to a camera
company it's like think of something so
cheap and easy that everyone can use it
that it becomes the standard mm-hmm you
know it's like well could be YouTube's
quality we'd be under - yeah sure good
to have better features yeah sure but
yeah good enough it works for enough
people I have a copyright question for
you okay all right so there's this law
that's being debated in the EU I came
here it's called like article 13 13 13
you can tell you can remember it because
it's the 13 easy to remember now if I'm
not mistaken what this article 13 those
is that what this 13th article provides
for is if you are a website and you are
hosting copyrighted content you can be
sued for hosting that copyrighted
content is that correct yeah I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure you can get sued so
yeah so for example somebody uploads
a TV show a movie to YouTube and oh you
two got caught with that TV show on
their servers distributing it rather
than the person who uploaded the video
being in trouble
YouTube's now in trouble and they can
get sued for that it's like it's like
having a dumpster that says no bodies
and then you put a body in there and the
dumpster of company is like oh [ __ ] and
they get in trouble they get in trouble
[Laughter]
that's a bad thing
that's like no no and hold on let's make
a better analogy it's like having a
peaches shop no it's like having where
you proceed so so right now the way your
copyright works is that so you have to
file a complaint and then they website
must take down the item that you fell to
complain against you can't just sue them
right out outright for having that that
item on there it's for example somebody
reuploads one of our videos on Facebook
happens all the time we had to say hey
Facebook please take it down and then
Facebook takes it down that's the end of
it we can't sue them they're not in
trouble we just they just take it down
and that's that yeah
so the U is passing law that's going to
make supposedly going to make these
websites responsible for that content
yeah they're accountable for not having
like copyright infringement so element
because it's yeah I think it's it's
pushing the blame from or not pushing
pushing the responsibility from the
content creator the copyright holder
mm-hmm yeah I'm just the person hosting
the content now yeah
YouTube is super against article 13
there in fact they're so against that
that I actually got an email from the
CEO of YouTube sent out to all youtubers
so you probably got it too saying hey
please tell people not to vote for
article 13 this is going to totally ruin
us obviously obviously they're against
it because they're going to be in the
crosshairs yeah now part of me sees how
that's a bad idea I can see how YouTube
the YouTube gets so much video uploaded
to them like they are going to be
screwed if they have to deal with that
but the other part of me a part of me
that hasn't had my videos uploaded on
Facebook over and over and over in
facebook is making dollar after dollar
in ad sales against those videos all
that
finn's let me catch him on it even with
videos with 40 million view is evident
like hearted from you and they go oops
yeah we'll take it down yeah yeah sure
we'll do that and that's but they've
made thousands of dollars off of it and
we don't see any of it
Harmonie wants to watch the world burn
yeah part of me does too because I mean
I've seen stuff too like um not gonna
provide references but you know second
third hand fourth hand you know like
even apparently there's been someone at
twitch accidentally just casually said
something about how they wouldn't shut
down your stream if you're streaming
copy written movies as long as you don't
save the video later you know as long as
it's there and you're not saving it to
your channel and so there's there are
like you have to find URLs obviously
you're not gonna just like build us just
search it or it's not appearing on
switches you know yeah trending page
page but apparently there's tons I'm out
there you know it's just base it's like
movie night we're just like streaming
and in anything TV shows copy written
content whatever and which is just kind
of like yeah whatever just don't worry
about it
we're not like you're just yeah
streaming Game of Thrones and until
someone until someone from HBO tells us
we're not gonna do anything about it and
it's most cuz it makes it money yeah
they're making money off I mean this is
that's the thing if article 13 goes
against their own self-interests now we
have to ask yourself you ask yourself
does that go against your self interests
a little bit but yes and no like I'm not
in the business of ripping off other
people's content oh really oh really
because I do make fan films oh we make
it a Dark Souls video tomorrow I'm not
just I'm not doing react videos where I
take somebody else's video play it the
whole entirety the video right you're
totally right actually what we're doing
is I mean if we just scrub the Mario
logos from some of the hats a lot of the
stuff is protected under parity law
that's the distinction yeah that's the
distinction because this way I tell
people they said aren't you gonna get in
trouble for making a video with it like
a video game character it's like yeah
maybe and if they don't want us to do it
we'll take it down but I'm not making a
video
another TV shows character in it or
another movie shoot movies character in
it yeah I'm not like taking someone's
work and redoing it it's more of like
I'm taking someone's idea obviously
ideas are work yes
I mean it's closer to saying I mean
let's be real it is kind of a form of
like copyright it is it's it's a form of
copyright borrowing / infringement in
the sense that someone invents a
challenge that involves a watermelon the
watermelon challenge and we do the
watermelon challenge so we are
infringing on their water you know it's
like we're infringing on the watermelon
challenge now in the sense that we took
the idea of taking a watermelon and
doing the special thing with it you know
it's like it's closer to that challenge
it's like the idea of something we are
we are taking that idea and then
building off of it I think it's more
like this if we were doing like we like
Dark Souls or playing Dark Souls if we
went out and made a fan Dark Souls game
yeah shut us down but there's no Dark
Souls show well yeah it's not it's not
like when you make a video that you're
directly competing with what the company
makes like that's why somebody was
making like a halo RTS back from the day
and they got shut down I can imagine
yeah because they're making a video game
that's going to directly compete with
halo yeah yes we can't just go out there
make a game of Thrones fan film and
spend a bunch of money on it okay can
you make a game of Thrones board game
obviously no you here's the thing you
can make a game of Thrones rule set yes
does that mean like you could make a D&D
campaign for Game of Thrones and you can
post the campaign online for people to
play or you could invent what if I call
it Game of Thrones that's fine if you're
not if you're not making money off of it
if you it really I guys I can't with an
idea this is a board game you can make
yourself you have to draw the board you
got to come up with pieces and here's
the rules make it yourself but this
might I had this idea okay I see what
you're getting up that's why I was
getting I don't think I know it's
regardless of its lethality I don't
think anyone's going to come after you
yeah for that well I don't think they
could because that's in the realm of
like freedom of X what if the idea is so
good it's like dude this have you played
Nico's Game of Thrones board game idea
you know and everyone's like yeah it's
really it's sweeping the
it's the first open-source board game
and it's based on Game of Thrones
Indiana Thrones is like oh crap oops
you're like I mean well they they can
shut down anybody trying to print the
board and they can shut down anybody
trying to like use their copyrighted art
what if it's a PDF well here's the
reality it may delete it when you create
art part of you is giving that art away
yeah you are when you create something
that's part of popular culture it's no
longer yours it's part of cultures this
is one of the things that passes that
know that well that's the noble opinion
I don't think it's the legal one it may
not be the legal one but does it quite
doesn't really quite matter because at a
certain point the popular opinion
Trump's the legal one which is to say
this is kinda what bugs me about Star
Wars currently under Disney but Luke
Skywalker doesn't belong to Disney Luke
Skywalker belongs to every person that's
what your heart tells you
Star Wars yeah it's true it's true but
what does your mind tell you it's become
part of lore now mine tells you that
Disney who gets to own Luke Skywalker
totally your 2200 Disney's the only one
who gets the profit off of Luke
Skywalker Yeah right yeah but if my kid
wants to dress up and pretend he's Luke
Skywalker Disney decant come in and shut
that down
I guess that's true well no I mean he's
buying the costume so but I do think
it's important and as we come up against
Mickey Mouse's retirement here into a
public domain and Disney probably tries
to extend it again first off look
Congress just give Disney and exception
for Mickey Mouse specifically come on
President Snow for that one guy who's
still a mascot of the company I get it
just make a single exception for that
character but beyond that all works
become public domain come on
secondly you're screwing it up the rest
of us secondly I think it's super
important that stuff becomes public
domain when something's become part of
culture you need to acknowledge that it
becomes part of culture and it's no
longer yours you lose a certain amount
of control over it yeah definitely and I
think that's going back to this article
13 thing let's wait can I can wrap it up
real quick with our perspective on it so
you were saying hey we rip off all these
video games make videos about them
you're right okay and somebody else made
a dubstep guns - we made it dubstep
becoming someone and somebody else made
a dubstep guns - and they are directly
competing
you know baby you know what and we let
it happen because one they put a ton of
work into it
- it's good in three you know what they
didn't just it's they're not just
ripping our video and re uploading it
that's one thing that's stealing our
work but this is them like taking that
idea and telling more of a story they're
doing exactly why I say which is once
the idea is out there it kind of belongs
to everybody and they told more of that
story and we could have still made a
dubstep guns - yeah what's because we're
super chill but you look at the Apple or
Google they are not chill well maybe
they should chill yeah yeah I mean so
that's how article 13 I don't know well
you wanna watch the world burn or what
yes but but but but but the promise is
that okay ultimately like like backing
up for a second
whose livelihood doesn't truly affect
you know the problem is is the promise
is that it creates a rule set that is
very hard to enforce when you deal with
parody and make these shades of gray
here you know like we would definitely
get caught in the crossfire yeah exactly
so what about every single video we had
that's always hundred-percent that
Google algorithm would like go nuts it's
like going to beast mode dudes start
scanning every frame and it sees one
Mario and it's like offline you know
it's like and it sees an Acura logo on a
card
copyright dejected you know and it just
goes it'll go nuts but maybe that's been
the inspiration people need to realize
that copyright laws might need to be
reworked
yeah well path of least resistance
sometimes you have to have things be a
bit painful for people to get motivated
to do something about it well I mean
this is the problem though with this
space we're entering where it's like
ideas and content and like these like
ideas become relatively tangible so
quickly and they're so you know they
multiply very quickly with YouTube
especially when creating derivative
content you know someone makes a meme or
makes a video and then millions of
people rip it and react to it and we
upload it and so it's kind of like well
it's kind of part of the culture in a
sense that like copyright is meaningless
yeah you know and so I guess that kind
of goes back to what you're saying you
make something in its public you know
obviously you put up as many barriers as
you can so that at least you don't go
bankrupt
yeah I think here's the distinction
copyright on your work is not
meaningless like if I painted a picture
you don't get to just take that picture
like that's my painting I don't need it
if you like what I pay and you're like
boy that's a really cool painting of a
dinosaur I want to make a painting of a
dinosaur that's where you should be able
to make as many paintings of dinosaurs
as you want you just don't get to take
my painting without my permission
I lost we have a time machine yeah yeah
well because that's what I'm doing right
now for that top ten book it's like in
my in-between time between stuff over
the last few days we finished this we
finished editing the second draft of
that book and we what is this book I I
mean well just to be clear with the
audience here I know this book is I'm
returning am you the audience well so
we've been working on putting a book
together called top 10 games you can
play in your head by yourself David and
myself are editing it because we're
basically good David loved it a good
friend and collaborator helped us on on
that tether stuff back in the day and a
bunch of other things but we've been
editing this book down basically we're
taking these very strange single player
D&D style games they're very hard to
describe imagine you know okay here's
the best example you're on a road trip
with a few people and you're bored and
you come up with the game like 20
questions or ghosts or any of these like
driving games that are don't they don't
require tools or game pieces or boards
or dice or anything but imagine a game
like that that you can play with one
person
mm-hm and we are taking this collection
of these games and editing them down to
the 10 best that we have found and we
are also working on trying to illustrate
some of the more difficult concepts that
we found and so by doing that I'm
reaching into the depths of old like
engravings and lithographs from the
1800s that kind of
kind of fit the style you know we're
tucked around a Theban around a little
bit around Dungeons & Dragons since
that's kind of one of the closest
approximations to this book but so so
old old lithographs and stuff like that
had that line drawing style and
basically I'm digging into the depths of
the 19th century when that illustration
style was very popular because of you
know photography was still relatively
difficult and we're basically using yeah
all this old hundred year plus work as
kind of our filler imagery so that way
we don't go bankrupt doing crazy custom
illustrations for everything so so yeah
it's uh it's been a very interesting
process but you know you have to go to
Getty Images you know and you have to
chop up their stuff because you know
ultimately it's public domain mmm and
says Getty Images all across it but
you're like you know thanks for scanning
it but you know so are these games you
can actually play by yourself oh yeah
you can definitely play them by yourself
we've tried and it works and really
gnarly there's some pretty crazy
experiences yeah we've even have some
reviews from other users or some people
who've tested them out so it's a very
intense stuff so but well we're gonna
actually we'll do more on this next year
this is this is this is something that's
still being built but you should do it
you should have a twitch channel for you
just playing the games by yourself super
fun to watch that would turn into an
avant-garde live striving videos and
they have like art films they have yet
to have art streams yeah they did they
happen I haven't done it yet what would
be your art strengths my art stream I
don't know I don't think anybody needs
one you'd be the first and no one would
care yeah copyright huh but I mean it's
a it's a good question though because I
think people got to figure it out
there's more creators mmm and more
people doing stuff than ever and I don't
know it's kind of like we're dealing
we're
we're using old-world thinking for new
world problems in a way and I feel like
we haven't finally fully cracked it
because that whole like article 13 stuff
is uh it's it's kind of old world
solutions to new world problems in a way
where you're like oh yeah just uh you
know you know just sue them when they
just have your content under there
because what's the analogy you know it's
like maybe have a bean factory and I
somehow make beans cost nothing to
produce and I've someone steals them and
puts them in a safety deposit box at the
bank and then I the bank gets in trouble
for putting there's the stolen bean
isn't there knowingly you know they tell
me money laundering is you know banks
can't knowingly take money I guess so
that's the thing it does the bank get in
trouble when they can't see into the
safety deposit box of a criminal you
know like Mandy took the hand of a
victim the murder though evidence is
being knowingly had it and yeah but okay
I guess you could argue that you do
doesn't knowingly have operator can see
that's kind of this issue it's like
they're creating this space they're
creating the dumpster farm where people
can roll in and dump their bodies and
they're like well that promise we don't
check every dumpster every day you know
how we know that they're being
accessories to murder yeah you know but
like I was like let's good maybe you
shouldn't have your dumpster farm be so
big so you can actually like keep tabs
on what's happening there yeah that's
that's the analogy here so or you're
trying to my dumpster [ __ ] the body
dumpster farm maybe see there you go
there you go
I mean maybe like I think YouTube
struggling a little bit with AI right
now because like YouTube's create this
platform of like incredibly open and I
don't mean open in like the censorship
sense I mean open and they like anybody
could upload videos as much as they want
all the time data open like they have
they're saying ever to gets unlimited
data to upload stuff yeah and they have
a bit of an issue now like I seen a lot
of channels that people are just trying
to make money regurgitating content and
I'm like I'll see some it has like
thousand videos on the channel and they
all have like fifty to eighty views and
they're just trying and trying and
trying and trying and trying and you
know the definition of insane too quick
bait people I guess trying to make money
off their videos and wait for one to pop
and I guess for some reason people get
in their heads that oh I made nine
hundred videos I got 50 views this
one those 900 first video same exact
video but it's I think this one's gonna
get a million a fuse but no you know
life doesn't work that way
definition of insanity is wasn't this
isn't the actual definition this like
the clothes is the one in Far Cry 3 Far
Cry 3 definition of insanity is
repeating the same thing and expecting
different results it's not how I heard
it but far cry 3 1 well it was different
that's as much but it's somewhat similar
it is very similar but I feel like
YouTube shooting themselves a little bit
in the foot with her setup and I trying
to avoid making this a YouTube central
my oh my god
what YouTube's like a pyramid scheme how
so it's like people like saying go start
YouTube channels who start YouTube
channels and then they say go start
YouTube channels on their YouTube
channel so that people listen to them I
know you know the pyramids at all right
and wide and Wyatt why do you know how
long you know what the first building
was that was taller than the parents no
Eiffel Tower Wow for 10,000 years
nothing was taller than the pyramids Wow
yeah well that's because they just kept
building smaller and smaller breaks all
the way up until they couldn't make a
smaller brick that's really that's a
really interesting fact just yeah your
pyramid schemes made me think of that
rain effect but ami you know the YouTube
algorithm spelled her own watch time
supposedly that's what every say is
watch time while shine watch time watch
time is king and we all seen those
tutorials it was like I look up a recipe
how to make a delicious hamburger the
section of the recipe I've looked up
already know how to make delicious
hamburger that's beside the point
you look up a recipe how to make a
delicious hamburger and the video is 10
minutes long and the thing is YouTube's
emphasized to watch time so much
everybody's bloated these videos that
don't need to be bloated maybe that's
what YouTube learning is all about
they've killed the concept of editing
the concept of brevity
making your edits tight and making your
content clear and concise because people
don't like their time wasted YouTube's
algorithm has killed that because they
were warned islands of people it's been
destroyed they've ruined it
that's pretty well you know okay yeah so
it's it's gonna lead to some
repercussions these happening yeah okay
relaxing mode because we're gonna I
think break here in a minute I think we
have to break but basically you know
I've noticed a lot of these
conversations we've had in this room so
far gravitate towards the concept of the
YouTube algorithm yeah and obviously you
know we're all so far you know Mike he
is an on and off relationship with
YouTube Harley I'd even argue well no he
had an on-and-off relationship with
YouTube for a little there but he's a
YouTube you know with these guys are
youtubers youtubers Jake Jake Robertson
youtuber we're all youtubers and so it's
like you know it's it's hard steering
away from this topic I've definitely
noticed but it's also because it's
something you know we care so much about
it affects our livelihood but what I
find interesting about it and why I feel
like each time we talk about it
something new pops up is because it's
it's actually a symptom of a greater
trend that all industries and all people
are being affected by right now even if
you're not talking about video if you're
not talking about one particular form of
communication you know we're looking at
it with Amazon we're looking at with
Apple and stuff like that and like we're
looking at it and our day to day lives
how it affects us you know it affects
our commute you know to know you know it
affects that every every single aspect
it affects how we feed our family mmm
you know and and it's this concept of
like I I guess it we're hitting a stage
in humanity officially where we're
letting robots make decisions for us and
we are crossing our fingers that we
taught the robots the right thing well
currently we've taught them that editing
doesn't matter
you should bloat your videos out as long
as you can yeah use iMovie on your phone
and not premiere
guess that's one lesson the robots have
been taught so far well I don't know if
this is the case for everybody but views
have been down for us - Leon the
corridor channel because corridor has
been corridors like the entertainment
industry in the economy
it's recession-proof yeah well it's kind
of like the it's like the javelin at the
Olympics it's been around forever you
hook this thing as hard as you can into
the air and hopefully it hits the target
yeah and sometimes it hits the target
and sometimes it doesn't
yes
you know you've been you've thrown some
great analogies tonight I don't know
where you're going with that one just
like I don't know where that javelin was
gonna land what one javelin yeah by the
person who's definitely not qualified to
be throwing them but you know on other
channels on-quarter crew and unknown the
views have been a little bit down
you're not significantly but it's there
was a change in the trend and it started
actually when they removed Google+ I
think they kind of screwed up a little
bit of the algorithm it's like that but
I think what's actually happening
because you don't really hear a lot of
youtubers complaining about it whereas
last time the ad pocalypse happened and
yeah PewDiePie wasn't making not
PewDiePie but you know rice gun wasn't
making quite as much money as he used to
and it was making videos complaining
about it last time that happened you
know a lot people talked about it now
people aren't really talking about it
and I think it's because this is all
conspiracy this deep conspiracy theory
here like I said I think YouTube's
getting less use right now I think
YouTube is losing traffic I don't think
it said that they were losing it to
twitch or anything like that I think
that their philosophy of watch time
because they wanted people to spend more
time on the site has finally caught up
to them they're paying the price yeah
they've encouraged garbage they've
encouraged filler they've encouraged
your time to be wasted and you have to
actively fight against their system to
find good stuff and stuff that doesn't
waste your time yeah some people got
time to burn a lot of kids got a lot of
time to burn and that's great they can
burn as much time as they want but the
rest of us that's awesome I like this
theory a lot I think this is great well
it's it's part of this it's part of them
figuring out what the heck's going on
and what they should do with the
platform but
it's also a symptom of trying to train a
robot yeah to run your company I think
starting to hurt them because I think
everybody who's not a kid who doesn't
have a lot of free time is over it and
they're searching for their content
elsewhere yes is like Netflix where they
can just I watch like Joe Rogan podcasts
is the only other thing I'm really I the
only thing I consistently watch on
YouTube right now and l2 and l2 and
level too because he's he is concise and
yeah he does this look about watch time
I think he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything yeah he like goes up there
dunks quickly edits gets us point out
pieces yeah everyone should go check out
l2 Inc it's one of the best YouTube
channels that's ever existed
definitely yeah it's basically for those
of you who don't know it's a director
it's the professor of marketing digital
marketing like that at NYU who basically
researches trends for all these
companies and every week he makes a
video where he goes out he shares good
knowledge because he owns a research
firm and he shares it with everybody
he explains like how it's helping or
messing up the industry good moves bad
moves the way it's influencing the way
people work and it's super insightful
it's backed up with research yeah and
like he's so open with it and he's super
entertaining yeah exactly exactly
it takes the worlds of big tech and
takes concepts like shareholder values
and all these it's effectively like
legalese of the corporate world he takes
these concepts that are pretty
unapproachable unless you're directly
involved with it in your day to day life
and is able to kind of help you
summarize what all these quarterly
earnings and loss that reports actually
mean for companies and trends and
products and the kind of stuff that you
know you deal with on a day to day basis
morals to yeah any and it's its
responsibilities to the world yeah it's
yeah yeah exactly
fantastic stuff so yeah I can only
aspire one day to be an authority like
he is on something so oh I can try to
talk about our watch time conspiracy
theories for YouTube and how it's making
the platform get less views right now I
don't think I think the Google+ removal
obviously affected things a little bit
but I think also YouTube might be
dealing with a little bit of a fallout
from their watch time algorithm at
so that's my conspiracy theory I love it
I think that's a great conspiracy theory
to end and things on right now because I
believe it's time to go film some other
fun stuff here very excited to move on
most other stuff oh node is not
happening anymore
well because Friday because we're
shooting dim souls right damn son
mmm dim sum all right boys it's been
good good old times here yeah fun yep
good catching up I think we got to level
one here
game of reference feel like we should do
another founder's experience the
founders experience we should be level
two where we go deeper because I think
our our work lives are interesting but
going into our personal lives I think
would also be interesting as well
because it's a whole nother side to us
and it doesn't get shared on the court
or crew videos yeah because it's not
loopy or zany it's bland and boring and
great for a podcast like this where you
can ramble for an hour
interesting dang it I go home when I
watch some TV and make dinner every
night before I'm gonna sleep and wake up
and that's what being a filmmaker is all
about is about bird somehow pretending
getting pretending that your life is is
actually super cool and crazy because
it's just because you know how to take
the right angle of it yeah actually hey
before I go Sam what's the secret to
making a popular video secret to making
a popular video is to ideally find
something that is popular and you
actually really like to and then giving
it a hundred percent
cool that's the secret to making
something popular yeah
and then there's making views which is
well we talked about this with Mike
there that's the merger of best actually
no no no no no making something really
popular is all about taking something
that you really really like and you have
never seen done before and making it
happen
that's who make things popular you also
fail doing that too hmm
so sometimes you like things making
things popular is all about stealing
yourself from failure and repeating hmm
and then also the only one to give up
well everyone thank you for tuning into
the corridor cast podcast if you are not
subscribed to the YouTube channel its
youtube.com slash corridor cast we
actually have little clips here that pop
up as well if you want to check out the
video portion that goes with the audio
or you can listen to this cast on your
favorite podcast retrieval service
whatever that might be yeah that's cool
it's super cool I'll do an outro -
alright yeah cuz we're supposed to cut
and then do an outro are we or supposed
to you're worried we're doing the intro
now the problem is this is this is the
issue we're both doing intros help us
we're supposed to do it like this we're
supposed to do like cut outro starts
thanks everyone for watching and
listening to this podcast don't forget
to subscribe on youtube and all the
podcast platforms that are out there we
really appreciate all your listening and
your minutes with us also if you want to
support us since this is a free show
head on over to court or digital dot
store and pick yourself up a a dandy
t-shirt to keep yourself warm from the
elements t-shirts keep you really warm
they keep the wind from hitting the nips
and that's all I need it for all right
no okay but cool and that's the outro